quando estamos estressados ou
estressadas nosso corpo libera hormônios
como o cortisol que pode levar um
aumento na produção de ao no estômago
irritando o revestimento do órgão e
causando inchaço o estresse também pode
levar a uma diminuição do fluxo
sanguíneo e retardar a digestão causando
assim um acúmulo de gases você já deve
ter ouvido falar na síndrome do
intestino irritável da sigla si I que é
um transtorno funcional do sistema
digestório que provoca sintomas como dor
abdominal enchaço e alterações no trito
intestinal muitas vezes ligado a
sentimentos como estresse e ansiedade
descobrir se alguém tem essa síndrome
pode ser bem difícil porque o
diagnóstico não é direto é feito por
exclusão de outras doenças e os médicos
focam nos sintomas e na relação com o
emocional outras condições parecidas
como o cibo o cifo intolerâncias
alimentares doença celíaca e doenças
leves no intestino podem ser confundidas
com a síndrome do intestino irritável
deixando o diagnóstico e tratamento mais
complicados